[Music]
on this sunday night another coved surge
to start the school year
how parents are preparing while citing
concerns about the return to classrooms
better masks and 95s if possible better
filtration plus a teenager traveling
alone turned away what i was hoping for
is just some empathy and some concern
for my child what led to her stressful
sleep outside of a boarding gate and how
the airline is responding and the team's
taking a stand against the human cost of
this year's fifa world cup
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
across the country health officials are
grappling with how to stem the surging
tide of covid 19 cases especially in
canada's two largest provinces global
news has confirmed ontario's cabinet is
meeting today to discuss possibly
implementing additional covet 19
restrictions in neighboring quebec
demonstrators took to the streets of
montreal last night to protest a curfew
that went into effect on new year's eve
[Music]
police arrested one person and handed
out nearly 60 fines the province-wide
curfew prohibits people from leaving
their homes between 10 pm and 5 a.m
there's also a ban on private gatherings
schools in quebec will stay closed until
at least january 17th several other
provinces are holding off on a return to
in-person learning for at least a week
though students in some provinces are
set to return to classes as early as
tomorrow as julia foy reports in our top
story tonight there are many concerns
about what's needed to prevent the
spread of the omicron variant in schools
spending a day in the clean fresh air is
a gift because children will soon be
back in school and covid may be too
realistically there's going to be some
kids in a class of 30 who
probably have coveted if your kid is not
feeling well please don't send your
child to school as parents prepare to
send their kids back into the classroom
it's all about masks masks and more
masks you tuck it in and then that helps
when it's on a face it helps decrease
the gaps around the side bc family
physician dr anna wallach has three
children in elementary school i'm making
sure
and every other physician physician
parent i know is making sure that their
kids are going to school with proper
properly fit fitted masks that are
certainly not the cloth masks of
yesteryear we're done with that and
we've upped our kids to n95 masks
parents and teachers are also pushing
for more time to ensure better air
quality and free medical masks those
hepa units and better masks have not
been provided yet the fact that
children between ages 5 to 11 have only
just
been started to
get vaccinated the third line in the
sand involves better monitoring of covet
cases and ontario has already indicated
it will not be providing notification to
parents without the information
knowing you know how many cases are
occurring in schools classrooms and
schools
how do you know what's going on how do
you know what's happening with co-fit
families are pushing back it's important
for the kids to go to school but it is
scary to not know the cases coming out
of the classroom i'd like to be given
the chance to make a decision of whether
or not we send our kids to class the
next day and teach their own on that but
i would like to know as cloven numbers
continue to skyrocket across the country
they're growing questions about how long
we can keep our kids in class i don't
know how that's going to look which is
which is kind of worrying because when
we look at the community numbers the
transmission in the community they're
significantly high and that's without
the positive rapid tests that people are
doing at home julia foy global news
vancouver
in the u.s many colleges and some school
districts are going virtual after the
holiday break but other schools are
opening now millions of parents will
also have to make the tough decision
whether or not to send their children
back to school this comes as the fast
spreading omicron variant and winter
weather continue to cancel flights right
across the country frustrating holiday
travelers who are anxious to get home
jennifer johnson has the latest
as florida and new york shattered daily
records for new covenant 19 cases
schools in those states and most across
the country will reopen monday
pediatric hospitalizations in america
are at their highest level since the
pandemic began leaving many parents
divided on whether it's safe for their
children to return to the classroom my
concerns is that my child may go to
school and contract kovic and bring it
home to the family as long as
everybody's keeping an eye on it and
protecting each other
i think that's the way to go right now
many colleges are going virtual
temporarily most local school systems
are giving families rapid at home test
kits as part of a test to stay strategy
endorsed by health experts advising the
white house we now can vaccinate
children from five years of age and
older i plead with parents to please
seriously consider
vaccinating your children
wearing masks in the school setting
doing tests to stay on monday the food
and drug administration is expected to
give approval to pfizer's booster shot
for 12 to 15 year olds to try and slow
the spread in that age group another
concern how many teachers will be
sidelined by the fast spreading omicron
variant it has already put its
stranglehold on the airline industry
which was forced to cancel more than 8
000 flights worldwide this holiday week
airlines did not see this new variant
coming if pilots and flight attendants
and gate agents can't go to work how can
airlines run the schedule that they sold
to the public months ago
this weekend omicron and harsh winter
weather combined for a one-two travel
knockout more than 500 flights were
canceled in chicago alone thousands
across the country leaving airline
passengers stranded i've had to rebook
my
reservations for like four or five times
doctors warn things will get worse
predicting another post-holiday blizzard
of covid 19 cases i don't think you're
going to start to see a national peak
until we get into february because
there's parts of the country that really
haven't been hard hit by omicron yet and
the virus will spread around the country
americans are now starting 2022 the
third year of the pandemic with record
numbers of new cases rising
hospitalizations and essential workers
pushed to the limit again
jennifer johnson global news washington
here in canada winter weather has caused
hundreds of canceled flights in the last
week flying can already be stressful
especially during a pandemic and when a
teenager is traveling alone and is
forced to sleep overnight at an airport
departure gate it compounds the
frustration that's what happened to a 16
year old and her powerless mother ross
lord explains
being at the mercy of an airline can be
a downer as grace rowe learned while
flying alone on westjet from saskatoon
to halifax trouble with connecting
flights forced her to sleep overnight at
a departure gate i try to be like well
you know
just make the best of it
even though it's a terrible situation
and
and
i thought she was holding it together
pretty well after being delayed leaving
edmonton grace says she scrambled to
change planes in toronto she was turned
away at the gate then along with other
frustrated passengers her flight to
halifax was pushed back by more than 16
hours because i checked just because i
was looking to see what gate i'd be at
in toronto and i saw that it moved my
flight to 4 pm the next day
tempers boiled over
together passengers were more frustrated
by the airline's confusing explanations
the west just sent an email saying the
staffing issue and now when the
passenger just wants a hotel all of a
sudden they blame it on the weather that
rings hollow lukacs says blaming the
delays on de-icing allows west yet to
avoid paying for hotels for the stranded
passengers what i was hoping for is just
some empathy and some concern for my
child and for someone at some point to
just fill around what was going on and
try and help her
and no one did that as an experienced
flyer grace did not register as an
unaccompanied minor westjet told global
news its staff did offer help finding
her a hotel something grace's mother
told us was impractical at that point
the airline says it apologizes for any
additional stress and confusion it may
have caused
after 24 hours of traveling grace did
make it to nova scotia enjoying the
holidays with her family she's hoping
the return flight to saskatchewan in
early january goes more smoothly
ross lord global news
a long-standing human rights battle over
the indigenous child welfare system may
soon be over the canadian press is
reporting an agreement in principle has
been reached that will see ottawa pay
billions of dollars in compensation to
indigenous children harmed by the child
welfare system the deal is set to be
announced in ottawa this week with
indigenous leaders and federal ministers
set to give an update on tuesday
south africa's democracy suffered a huge
blow today after a major fire ravaged
the country's parliament
dozens of firefighters were still
struggling to contain the blaze hours
after it was reported early sunday there
are no reports of injuries the complex
was closed for the holidays police have
arrested a suspect who now faces arson
and theft charges but the damage to the
historic site is extensive
south korea's military has conducted a
search for an apparent defector who
crossed the heavily fortified border
into north korea late saturday night
surveillance equipment detected a person
inside the demilitarized zone that
divides the korean peninsula south
korean troops were unable to find the
individual later discovering the person
climbed a tall barbed wire fence around
6 40 p.m local time their fate
citizenship and motive is unknown though
reports suggest it was a civilian not a
soldier since the late 1990s more than
34 000 north koreans have defected to
the south but crossings in the other
direction are extremely rare
ahead sudan's prime minister steps down
after two more people are killed in
pro-democracy protests
there is a major political development
in sudan tonight the recently reinstated
prime minister has resigned abdullah
hamdak says there needs to be a new
agreement struck with the military in
order for the country to transition to
democratic rule he had returned to his
post just six weeks ago after he was
detained when the military seized
control of the country in october
earlier today at least two people were
killed in and around the capital
khartoum when security forces cracked
down on protesters who were demanding an
end to military involvement in the
country's government
after team canada brought home the gold
medal in women's soccer at the tokyo
olympics last summer 2022 could be
another historic year our men's national
team is in contention to qualify for its
first fifa world cup in 36 years the
tournament takes place in november in
qatar but the tiny gulf nation is under
scrutiny thousands of immigrant workers
have reportedly died during the enormous
construction project there others have
faced brutal working conditions as
redmond shannon reports some of the
teams going to qatar will be taking a
stand to highlight the issue
canada's 2-1 win over mexico in freezing
edmonton made canada's soccer fans
believe
believe that their team can get to a
world cup played in the desert heat
when the tiny gulf nation of qatar was
awarded the tournament there were
questions about the bid process and
about how a country the size of cape
breton island could host such a large
event
armies of construction workers from
south asia have since built eight new
stadiums plus hotels highways and even
an entire city but throughout there have
been concerns about the working
conditions many of them face unpaid
salaries it seems to be one of the
ongoing issues that they complain about
but they are trapped in the system
because they can't leave the country
they contain jobs unless the permission
of the very person who is responsible of
their abuses an analysis by the guardian
newspaper says more than 6 000 migrant
workers from south asia have died in
qatar in the past decade a large
proportion likely working on world cup
infrastructure many deaths simply
labelled as cardiac arrest the climate
conditions in qatar and the gulf are
very harsh in terms of you have at least
six months of the year where the high
level of humidity is high you're talking
about over 40 degrees under growing
pressure qatar introduced reforms in
recent years but human rights groups say
most workers have seen little change
there is a proper lack of investigations
into these deaths to understand why
these migrant workers are actually dying
in 2021 teams like germany and norway
have made gestures highlighting what's
happening in qatar the danish team says
it will do the same at the tournament
promising to only stay in hotels where
workers are respected if canada gets to
qatar not every fan will want to go i
can't get past the moral uh leap that it
would require to do that i i would feel
a little bit
dirty you know so to speak soccer
blogger tay sahota says he won't judge
others who go and thinks it's on
officials and governments to take a
stand rather than star players like
alfonso davies they can make changes in
a more subtle way
um
uh you know speaking with the media
doing things away from the play of field
that might be more subtle that doesn't
put them
at risk
so early into their younger careers but
before any moral dilemma presents itself
team canada has to get to qatar six huge
qualifying games still remain redmond
shannon global news london
helping millions on the move ahead can
world leaders step up to address the
global migrant crisis
[Music]
last month the u.n marked international
migrants day to shed light on people on
the move either by force or by
circumstance it's estimated more than 4
million people around the world are
considered stateless and that rises
almost 50 times when factoring in the
total number of people who fled their
homeland and as we begin 2022 the
challenge to help many of them is only
getting tougher reggie chichini explains
migration has been a part of the history
of humanity for millennia it's driven by
an urge to find something better or
leave something behind that made life
unbearable i think some people see the
the pictures of of suffering and they it
brings out sympathy others it brings out
fear
in recent decades instability and
conflict have put droves of people on
the move often migrants are met with
political pushback and intolerance it's
not going to stop in 2022. the u.s
mexico border often catches most of the
headlines as migrants from latin america
and in 2021 haiti flee for a better life
do not come
do not come
immigration policy in the united states
is contentious and politically charged
it's been criticized as inhumane and
there are calls for the country to step
up its resources to not only manage the
flow into the us but also help address
issues in migrants home countries and
what concerns me is that we're now eight
years into this crisis and while we're
seeing small increases in the resources
dedicated to deal with the problem once
it's here we really haven't seen the
massive surge of resources that's
required
for these kind of numbers
europe's migration crisis highlights the
peril many people face and the setbacks
of moving elsewhere
this year thousands of migrants who set
their eyes on the eu
touched down in belarus only to find
themselves used as political pawns by a
country intent on destabilizing the eu
we are like a ball like a ball in the
stadium
belarus and poland
they kick us
in france some migrants risk everything
to try and reach the uk
in the pursuit of a better life dozens
of migrants died crossing the english
channel in november in the worst
disaster on record this disaster
underscores how dangerous it is to cross
the channel in this way united nations
says 166 people have died that way since
2014. i think the question is how do you
get how do you create enough control
of the flows that are out there we must
transcend the immunity of our societies
against the vitals of hate the un
believes that in 2022 nearly 275 million
people will require humanitarian
assistance and protection
a task too great for any individual
nation a u.n agreement in 2018 saw 164
countries sign onto a pac to better
address migration the u.s wasn't
involved at the behest of then-president
donald trump migration is part of a
smart economic policy it's part of you
know it's part of population growth it's
part of of
learning and innovation diffusion of
ideas but you you start to to give it
some sort of form so that people feel
like there's a plan there that this is
not an army marching
north but rather a set of people who
were welcoming in
because they can become part of our
society that challenge will require
countries to work together to find a
solution we've been frozen in this
political debate where you have these
side two sides who can't find any
compromise and the stakes couldn't be
higher any crisis from natural disaster
to war could upend best laid plans at a
time when millions of people are already
risking everything in search of a better
life
reggie chikini global news washington
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm nitu garcia tonight
your canada is a frozen boundary bay in
delta bc we'd love to see your corner of
the country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational
globalnational.com thank you for
watching donna friesen will be back at
the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night